[موسيقى]
ثم ولد هذا المشروع لأننا
نحن شركة تكنولوجيا المعلومات و
الروبوتات كان لديه فضول
استخدام الدول التي هي
المعدات التي تخدم أ
توجيه الطاقة الشمسية للشمس
إشعاع في هدف ثم لدينا
التقى صديقنا الذي لديه
اقترح علينا عشاق القهوة
لاستخدام هذه التكنولوجيا من أجل
تحقيق التحميص الشمسي
قهوة
[موسيقى]
القهوة ، وليس الطبل الدوار
يسخن وفي الهواء أنه
يحتوي على نفس القهوة التي
أي تسخين أشعة الشمس
هذا يؤثر على حبوب البن
يسخن بدوره ثم يسخن الهواء
إنه يحيط به ولكن بشكل أساسي الجزء
أكثر سخونة مما دعنا نقول كل هذا
معا هو الحبوب نفسها
[موسيقى]
أجد هذا المقهى
عطرية خاصة ليست ثقيلة و
من بين جميع أنواع القهوة التي استخدمتها دائمًا
هذا هو واحد من أفضل مثل
النكهة وكذلك سهولة الهضم
[موسيقى]